wir wollen sprechen über ätsche 14 Jahre
alte erstochen auf dem Weg zur Schule in
Baden-Württemberg sie sagen dieses
Mädchen Teenager die keine Zukunft mehr
ist hat sie hätte noch leben können ja
sie hätte noch leben können und sie
würde noch leben wenn eine Politik
gehandelt hätte wie viele von ihnen
wissen oder der ein oder andere nicht
ich bin eine bekanntesten Kinderschützer
in Deutschland und aufgrund meiner
Arbeit mit Millionen von Menschen die
die begleiten und verfolgen bekomme ich
viele Hilfe und ich habe direkt nach
diesem Mord Anette ein Video gemacht und
habe da sehr klare deutliche Worte
gefunden und dann haben wir auch
Menschen aus dieser Stadt geschrieben
aus diesem kleinen Ort in der Kirche
oder in der Kirchberg und haben mir
Dinge gesagt Dinge die bekannt waren und
jetzt noch öffentlich werden und die
veröffentlich machen werden auch in BILD
am SONNTAG und noch andere Medien Dinge
die man komischerweise in anderen Medien
nicht erfährt so wurde schon im Sommer
diesen Jahres immer wieder statt der
Bürgermeister auf hingewiesen dass da
Übergriffe waren Kinder auch verfolgt
wurden belästigt wurden von diesen
Menschen die dort auch in diesem
Wohnheim waren und ob der jetzt der eine
oder andere psychisch krank war oder ob
nicht das soll jetzt erstmal hingestellt
sein aber es wurde nichts getan man hat
es ignoriert und ich habe hier eine
klare Botschaft wie viele Menschen
müssen noch sterben wie viele Menschen
müssen noch für eine Migrationspolitik
die nicht funktioniert
ihr Leben lassen wie viele Menschen
müssen hier noch
Opfer werden mir persönlich ist es ganz
egal woher jemand kommt welche Religion
er hat welche welche Kultur er hat der
mir geht es um die Menschen um jedes
Leben und hier ist ein Mädchen mit
türkischem Hintergrund zu Tode gekommen
erstochen worden getötet worden und ein
anderes Schwert verletzt worden und
wieder geht's nur darum ganz schnell
entweder wie sich hinzustellen und so zu
sagen was wir zu denken haben und wieder
mit der Nazi-Keule zu winken machtlos
den Mund auf dann haben wir drauf ich
rede darüber und zwar habe ich gesagt
wir denken an Würzburg hey Gedenken an
Frankfurt in Gedenken an Ludwigshafen
und jetzt in Gedenken an Iller Kirchberg
in Gedenken an etsche und in die denken
an jeden Menschen der in unserem Land
durch eine Politik mit zu Tode kommt die
nicht erkennt dass wenn man Menschen
nicht integriert sie nicht aufhängt
einfängt und vor allem indem man sie
unkontrolliert ins Land holt ohne zu
schauen welche Probleme sie schon
mittragen welche Gewalt oder welche
Kriminalität sie schon getragen oder ob
sie krank sind hierhin lässt und damit
die ganze Gesellschaft jeden Menschen
jede Kultur jeder Religion in Gefahr
bringt dieses kleine Mädchen könnte noch
leben übrigens genauso wie Leonie dessen
Mutter mit mir in Kontakt steht und wo
jetzt die Täter lebenslang und 19 und 20
Jahre bekommen hat in Wien und wir
vertreten die Eltern mit dabei um das
Land Wien mit zu verklagen und auch
Österreich mit zu verklagen und genau
das muss bei uns auch passieren wir
müssen die Politik in Regress nehmen wir
müssen hier auch dafür sorgen sie tragen
die Ver sorgen dafür wenn sie Menschen
und sein Land holen und nicht
kontrollieren die schmeißen ihre Pässe
weg und sagen sie sind 12 oder 14 und
sind 30 Watt stimmt ja nicht könnte man
überprüfen will man das Überprüfen nein
aber eins vorweg meine Kinder sind
polnisch meine Freundin hat muslimischen
Hintergrund und ich habe mehr türkischer
arabische Freunde als Deutsche und viele
Menschen schreien hier auf mit
Migrationshintergrund das ist keine
Frage welcher politischen Agenda man
angehört und jetzt wird die AFD sie sich
auch hinstellen und schreiben auch was
passiert denn hier alle haben hier
versagt aber die Frage ist wie viele
Menschen müssen noch sterben müssen die
Menschen integrieren wir müssen sie
kontrollieren und wenn Menschen wie hier
um Hilfe rufen Herr Bürgermeister und
sie ignorieren dann tragen Sie eine mit
Schuld und jetzt brauchen Sie sich nicht
vertuschen und es musste der ZDF sagen
oh das ist wieder wertig ein Mord aber
auch das zu instrumentalisieren
widerwärtlich sein Wort wieder werde ich
und asozial ist eine Politik die nur
ihren Interessen dient und die Bürger
entsteht ist alle Bürger egal welcher
Religion schützt die Bürger in unserem
Land
einzelnen jedes Leben ist wertvoll und
es reicht was hier abläuft es waren wenn
dieses Thema hochemotional sind wir
gestartet weil wir aber einmal tiefer
eintauchen Frau Kelle was kann man tun
damit solche Fälle möglichst nicht
passieren sagen wir es mal so wir haben
noch überhaupt nichts getan um insofern
haben wir die ist die ist die ist die
Spanne von dem was wir tun können extrem
hoch und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
habe auch eine 14-Jährige die morgens
das Haus verlässt und zur Schule geht
und ich möchte dass sie heil wieder nach
Hause kommt und ich möchte gar nicht in
einem Land leben wo ich mir Sorgen
machen muss und ich schreibe jetzt
selber auch als Publizistin seid seit
der migrationskrise 2015 muss ich mich
als Rassistin beschimpfen lassen weil
ich schon damals gesagt habe das was auf
der Kölner Domplatte passiert ist ist
ein zugewandertes Problem das ist ein
Problem dass wir vorher nicht hatten und
das heißt dieses Problem ist eigentlich
seit Beginn der migrationskrise bekannt
ja es ist nicht das erste Mädchen das
tot ist und schon gar nicht ist das
erste Mädchen das vielleicht
vergewaltigt wurde wir haben eine wir
haben so viele sexuelle Übergriffe
eigentlich müsste jede anständige
Feministin auf den Barrikaden sein in
Deutschland und gerade auch die Leute
die jetzt gerade in der Regierung sind
gerade auf die Grünen die sonst
irgendwie in diesem Thema immer ganz
vorne dabei sind ja alle schweigen
darüber niemand will dieses Fass
aufmachen wir haben gerade läuft im
Moment die Islamkonferenz in Deutschland
wir reden aber nicht über das Problem
über das problematische ist ein
muslimische Frauenbild zum Beispiel ja
also unsere Innenministerin fährt nach
nach Katar um dort die Frauenrechte und
die Schwulenrechte zu retten aber findet
keine Worte hier in Deutschland
angesichts dessen was hier Frauen hast
und Schwulen hat stattfindet von
demselben Klientel ja das heißt wir
retten die Welt irgendwo in Katar aber
wir stellen uns nicht den Problemen hier
und ich empfinde das gerade auch Frauen
gegenüber als unmöglich in diesem Land
weil Frauen und eben die jungen Mädchen
sind sozusagen die leichtesten Opfer ja
und wir sehen es ja auch immer wieder ja
wir sehen immer wieder dass das die
Frauen betrifft und sobald man auf das
Thema aufmerksam macht dann heißt es
dann kommt sofort die Rassismus Keule
und dann heißt es irgendwie man das ist
eine eine Täter Opfer Umkehr die hier
passiert und wir sind bereit in diesem
Land jedes jedes Wort eines alten weißen
Mannes gegen eine Frau irgendwie auf
eine Goldwaage zu legen aber wenn wir
Übergriffe haben von jungen schwarzen
Männern um es mal als Kontrast
aufzubauen dann gucken alle weg dann
gucken alle weg und der erste Schritt
der wäre in meinen Augen wir erstens mal
dass wir diese Grenzen schließen das ist
das erste was wir machen müssen dass wir
erstmal kontrollieren wer kommt in
dieses Land und hat er überhaupt den
Anspruch und ist er wirklich Flüchtling
und so weiter das heißt wir müssen
wissen wer es ist und zweitens müssen
wir alle rausschmeißen die illegal hier
sind ja ich verstehe es nicht und ich
bin auch nicht mehr bereit hier Menschen
sozusagen zu dulden in diesem Land die
Straftaten begehen und trotzdem nicht
ausgewiesen werden das ist auch der
Menschen nicht mehr klar zu machen warum
wir würden Ärger bekommen mit dem Gesetz
wenn wir anfangen auch nur falsche
Angaben irgendwie vom einwohnermelde
waren zu machen zu unserer eigenen
Person warum wir sind zu einer Witzfigur
geworden weltweit wir laden die Leute
ein wir kontrollieren nichts und wir
legen an unsere eigenen Bürger strengere
Gesetze an als an die Menschen die
angebliche herkommen nur weil sie unsere
Hilfe wollen
der soll sich wie ein Gast Benehmen eben
gerade hat Carsten Stahl das auch
angesprochen hat gesagt die Menschen die
kommen die werden auch alleine gelassen
die werden das ist das große Problem die
werden kommen vielleicht mit einem
Trauma hier an mit einer Vergangenheit
die wir nicht kennen und sitzen dann in
einer Unterkunft und werden nicht
betreut sie als Psychologin da steht man
noch in der Verantwortung
erschütternd wofür in Deutschland Geld
vorhanden ist und wofür kein Geld waren
ist und wenn man den Wunsch als ein
solches geistliches Land zu sein dann
muss man sich mit den Risiken was
schwere kriegst Traumata mit sich
bringen einfach auch bewusst werden da
kann man jeden Experten fragen das
bestimmte Frustration auch erschüttert
eine eigen Traumatisierung und auch ein
bestimmtes damit verbundenes Frauenbild
leider zu Übergriffen und Brutalitäten
der Art und Weise führen kann muss ja
auch sagen es trifft ja nicht jeden der
hier hinkommt der so drauf ist aber es
kann passieren und deshalb haben wir
eine Verantwortung dafür zu sorgen wo
diese Potenziale da sind mit Profis zu
arbeiten entweder Dinge zu leiten das
ist besser wird oder aber auch zu
erkennen wir haben ja eine Gefährdung
der Gesellschaft wenn ein fremd und
Selbstgefährdung vorhanden ist weil das
von mir ausgeht dann werde ich
eingewiesen in anderen Fällen fragt man
sich das nicht mal sich einer dafür
interessiert es interessiert sich keiner
dafür was in den Heimen stattfindet es
geht keiner hin sie können gerne
antworten nimmt der Starter seiner
Verantwortung war er starten nimmt
Verantwortung wahr aber nicht in
ausreichendem Maß also hier muss man ja
ganz klar sagen ist ein schrecklicher
Fall der symptomatisch ist für einige
Fälle die aufgetreten sind in gleicher
Weise und wenn man da schon ein musste
erkennt ja dann kann also man kann ja
sagen wenn es ein Einzelfall wäre ist es
nicht dann wäre es dann wäre es ja so
eine Sache über die man reden könnte
aber hier gibt's Muster und eine ganz
klare Tendenz und deswegen ist auch der
Start hier in der Verantwortung auch die
Politik ist da ganz klein erfahren wo
ist ja richtig was sie gesagt der Staat
der integrieren will der muss auch
Integrationsleistungen zulassen und auch
selber erbringen ich bin nicht ganz bei
Ihnen Frau Kelle ich glaube schon dass
ein Staat wie Deutschland eine gewisse
Verantwortung hat auch im Rahmen des
internationalen Völkerrechts es ist ja
so dass die jungen Menschen die aus der
Ukraine beispielsweise zu uns kommen
junge Mädchen die dort praktisch aus
Kriegsgebieten fliehen dass wir den
Schutz gewähren das ist auch völlig in
Ordnung
wir müssen diese Grenze soweit schließen
dass wir erstmal kontrollieren wir
reinkommen ich will das an dieser Stelle
noch mal sagen es ist auch richtig dass
einige
bevölkerungs-bereiche dort zu uns kommen
das sind auch Menschen die Schutz
verdienen und das müssen wir im Auge
behalten aber wir müssen auch unsere
eigene Bevölkerung schützen und das ist
die Verantwortung
nicht als
deutscher Bürger der christliche Glauben
äh angehört oder besser sagte ich habe
meinen eigenen Glauben aber ich rede für
alle ich spreche auch für viele Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund und das ist es
entscheiden ich habe viele tolle
Menschen wir es kommen auch Menschen in
unserem Land bereichern aber es kommen
nun mal auch Menschen die unser Land
gefährden wir hatten alleine im Jahre
2020 über 720 Gruppen Vergewaltigung und
dann kann man genau sehen wenn man sich
anguckt seit wann der ein oder anderen
Land ist so heißt das dass jeder unser
Land kommen vergewaltigt ist natürlich
nicht und übrigens wurden ja nicht nur
muss deutsche oder christliche Frauen
Missbrauch so eine asiatische mit
migrationshelferin jegliche Art und
Weise also müssen wir schützen genauso
ich verlange von der Bundesregierung
dass sie die Messe Attacken offen liegt
wie viele und wer vor allen Dingen die
Messerattacken macht das wird schön
gerne und natürlich gekehrt das sind
genau diese Probleme wenn wir in Berlin
Anfragen stellen das hatte ich ja schon
paar mal gesagt zum Beispiel Gewalt an
Schulen unter Verschluss Sache wir
wollten wissen wer die Verantwortlichen
Experiment sind und wir noch Internet
und genauso ist es hier der
Bürgermeister die haben sich alle hier
in meinen Augen haben die Blut an ihren
Händen und nochmal wir reden hier von
Würzburg in Frankfurt dieser Junge
hingeschubst wurde auf der Bahn wo die
Mutter ist immer wieder das gleiche
Muster und die hört mir auf mit dieser
Verlogenheit das wären Einzelfälle und
immer wenn man sagt kommen sie wieder so
wie jetzt der Herr vom ZDF der sagt
wiederwertig wenn man es
instrumentalisierte instrumentalisiert
niemand was aber wer die Realität nicht
sehen will lässt zu dass es wieder
passiert und ich möchte alle Kinder alle
Menschen unser Land schützen vor den
Gefahren und wer hier ins Land kommt hat
sich an die Regeln zu halten und ein
Arschloch ist ein Arschloch egal in
welcher Kultur wenn er diese regelrecht
muss halt Knast oder wenn er nicht mehr
tragbar ist muss er auch ausgewiesen
werden die weißen nichts aus im
Gegenteil sie holen noch mehr rein und
das darf nicht unkontrolliert Geschehen
ich will wissen wer ins Land kommt und
wenn sie sagen ich habe keinen Pass man
kann heute anhand knochenanalyse
feststellen wie alt ist wird nicht
gemacht man geht in Geld man geht in
Unterkunft und dann lässt man sich
selbst so fördert man keine Migration so
fördert man schlimm ist das angesichts
dessen was Herr Stahl da gerade sagt
jetzt mit all den Hintergrund die wir
hier auch zusammentragen eine gute Idee
die Hürden für einen deutschen Pass noch
zu senken ja das kommt darauf an für
welche Personengruppen sicherlich nicht
für gefährliche Gewalttäter die hier
schwerste Kriminalität begehen auch
nicht für andere ich will aber das
Augenmerk noch mal auf die Frage lenken
wie wir mit solchen Bevölkerungsgruppen
umgehen ich war sehr irritiert ich habe
das jetzt in Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus
Senat gesehen wir haben ja eine Gruppe
von Menschen aus Moldawien hier in
Berlin die eigentlich
ausreisepflichtig sind und die auch
abgeschoben werden soll und es hat
tatsächlich der Berliner Senat gegen den
Widerstand der inselnatorin übrigens
beschlossen dass die alle hier bleiben
können obwohl die teilweise straffällig
sind und das ist ein Punkt wo ich mich
frage was machen Linke und Grüne an der
stelle ich kann das nicht
nachvollziehbar bin ich da bin ich voll
bei ihm sowas kann es in einer
Demokratie nicht gehen weil wir sind ja
auch den Menschen hier verantwortlich ja
und das ist muss doch das primäre
Augenmerk sein natürlich haben wir
humanitäre Verantwortung aber wenn
Menschen hier straffällig werden und
wenn sie ausreisepflichtig sind dann
müssen sie raus ganz einfach ja aber das
ist ja ein Schema nicht nur in Berlin
sondern es ist ja tatsächlich ein Schema
dass ich durchzieht seit vielen Jahren
in der Politik also ich komme aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen dort hatte schon
damals die Ministerpräsidentin Kraft
gesagt wir weisen grundsätzlich nicht
aus ja das heißt das ist ja eine
Einladung für Straftäter oder auch die
Einladung dazu auf diesen Staat zu
betrügen wenn ich weiß es gibt keine
Konsequenzen und da muss man ja auch
schauen mit was für Menschen also was
wir was sind das für junge Männer aus
was für Gesellschaften kommen die die
verstehen tatsächlich nur die kommen aus
hierarchisch sehr klaren autoritären
Strukturen und die setzen wir jetzt hin
und und wenn Sie einen Fehler machen
kriegen sie überhaupt gar keine
Konsequenz das heißt die Wissen egal was
ich mache mein Geld bekomme ich ich darf
bleiben und dieses Land ist so blöd die
behalten mich hier ja das heißt wir
kommen auch hier sie könnten kein Kind
so erziehen wie wir das hier machen ja
sondern wir müssen wir müssen uns an
unsere eigenen halten es geht gar nicht
darum dass man sagt wir brauchen andere
Regeln sondern wir müssen mit dem
gleichen maßeinsatz Essen und
Psychologie
dass dass wir das Aufbrechen in einer
Begleitung also diese Werte zu
vermitteln diese eine so starke Prägung
eines hierarchischen Systems lässt sich
nicht in drei Wochenenden aufbrechen das
ist ganz klar das ist ein Anspruch den
man dann Therapeut etwas gar nicht
möglich ist aber man muss sich deshalb
bewusst sein an welchem Punkt man
tatsächlich da da ansetzt und welche
Gefährdung einfach da ist und dass davor
die Augen zu verschließen macht für alle
die Situation unerträglich also es macht
auch für die für die 95% der Ferien die
nicht Strafe sind weil die allen eine
Tonne geworfen werden also ich spiele
seit vielen Jahrzehnten Fußball wenn man
die Geschichten sich anhört was
schwarzafrikanische Fußball Freunde von
mir erleben müssen weil sie die gleiche
Tonne geworfen werden dann ist das
erbittert sehr bitter und die sagen ist
die sagen ja selber
es muss ein härtere Gesetze und härtere
Strafen her weil die deutsche Polizei
und der deutsche Staat wird als
lächerlich empfunden das Problem ist
bloß dabei sie wollen es nicht
ansprechen weil sie Angst haben dadurch
Hass und Rassismus zu führen aber genau
das Gegenteil passiert in dem sie mich
nicht ansprechen wirkt es wie vertuschen
und dadurch fördern sie Hass und
Rassismus und unterstützen die Parteien
die keiner will ja also geht offen damit
um seht den Probleme die Augen und
handelt und setzt doch um Berlin ist der
Sumpf des Versagens wie gesagt Schluss
Sache lächerliche Politik hier übrigens
haben sie betrogen weil man nicht
vergessen dann haben wir damit
aufgeklärt bei der Manipulation aber
entscheidend
meine Tochter ist 14 Jahre alt und ich
will nicht klarstellen wenn das meiner
Tochter angetan würde würde ich die Welt
aus den Angeln heben ich ich habe nicht
nicht die Politik ich stehe an den
Gräber 8 Beerdigung ich muss das hier
lesen
die Menschen verzweifelt sich bei mir
melden und mich um Hilfe bitten weil sie
niemand mehr vertrauen
Polizei teilweise das macht auch was mit
mir und das macht mir stinksauer weil
ich einfach nicht verstehe dass man
nicht schafft die Menschen in unser Land
zu schützen und wo wir schon beim
verdrängen sind wann die Menschen hat
den grünen ist steht irgendwann auch
nicht mal dem deutschen Volkes verbieten
wir auch noch war dem deutschen Volker
genau das heißt es alle die in
Deutschland sind sind das Volk die
Bürger im Land jeder Kultur aber diese
Politik ist links und auf grünen Auge
blind und folgt nur ihren Ding und wenn
es geht in Deutschland ist immer der
gefährlicher der die Missstände
anspricht anstatt der die Michelle macht
und zu beantworten hat die Politik
kriegt eine Mitschuld und trägt Blut an
ihren Händen für diese Toten und es
werden mehr wenn wir dich langsam
endlich aufwachen und Handeln ich glaube
es gibt durchaus Alternativen ich will
noch ganz kurze auf Frau Keller eingehen
sie haben ja die Politik von Rot Grün
unter Frau Kraft in NRW genannt der
Nachfolger war eine schwarz-gelbe
Regierung mit einem liberalen
Innenminister nämlich Handstand und da
hat er eine radikale Änderung wir haben
konsequent ausgewiesen wir haben
konsequent auch Bildungs nicht mehr
geduldete Personen aus die richtige
Person dort zurückgeführt das ist eine
alternative es gibt auch konsequente und
andere Politik das muss man auch der
Politik an einigen Stellen mal zugute
halten bei allem Verständnis für das was
sie gesagt